من اختيار المكان الى عدد الحاضرين رسائل
الاتحاد الاوروبي المتحديه لروسيا والرئيس
بوتين لا تتوقف في حرب عسكريه ودبلوماسيه
تبدو طويله الصوره الجماعيه لا تعني ان كل
من فيها يجمعنا على انضمام اوكرانيا الى
اسره الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف شمال الاطلس
قريبا كما تشاء كييف عنوان القمه المجموعه
السياسيه الاوروبيه حضرها ما لا يقل عن 50
من القاده الاوروبيين الاعضاء وغير
الاعضاء في الاتحاد وابرز المشاركين
الرئيس الاوكراني فلوجي ميرسي الذي حضر
شخصيا الى بلده
مكان انعقاد القمه تبعد 20 كيلومتر فقط عن
اوكرانيا خلال كلمته اوضح الرئيس زيلينسكي
ان عدم منح العضويه الكامله في الاتحاد
وحلف النيتو لن يكون له سوى بديلين هما
اما حرب مفتوحه او احتلال روسي زاحف
الرضاعه
علينا ان نتذكر ان كل شك نظهره هو خندق
ستحاول روسيا احتلاله وكل شك يجلب المزيد
من انعدام الامان
كلامهم موجه للمعترضين او الداعين الى
تاجيل منح كييف العضويه لاسباب سياسيه
تختلف من برلين الى واشنطن مرورا
والكلام عن الدعم غير المسبوق والمستمر
لكييف وحده غير كاف
الذي يطالب بضمانات امنيه بعد انتهاء
الحرب لم يصله من اسلوب ما يثلج صدره
ثلاثه ملفات متشابكه وشائكه كانت على جدول
اعمال وزراء خارجيه حلف شمال الاطلس في
اجتماع البحث عن تسويات بشان انضمام
اوكرانيا خلافه الامين العام الحالي
والنفقات العسكريه البحث عن تسويات يعني
وجود انقسامات حتى وان عمل الامين العام
على اظهار الوجه المشرقي للحلف والله
العظيم
كل اعضاء الحلف متفقون على ان ابواب
الناتو مفتوحه لعضويه دول جديده وكل
الاعضاء متفقون على ان اوكرانيا ستصبح
عضوا في الحلف وهذا قرار تتخذه الدول
الاعضاء وليست موسكو هي من يرفض او يقبل
توسع النيتو
ليس كل الاعضاء على وفاق بشان تسريع عمليه
الانضمام وخاصه في اوجه الصراع العسكري
المتحفظون على تحديد جدول زمني وخريطه
طريق واضحه كما يطالب زيلينسكي بالحاح
يخشون من تفعيل الماده الخامسه من ميثاق
النيتو في اليوم الاول من انضمامها ما
يعني دخول كل الاعضاء في حرب مباشره مع
موسكو وهذا ما لا تتمناه وعشره وبرلين
غياب تسويه في اوسلو يعني احتدام النقاشات
في قمه فيلينيوس المقرره في يوليو المقبل
كثره التجمعات حلفاء كياف بالنسبه الى
روسيا معركه دبلوماسيه اخرى مع الغرب الذي
يعمل على حصلها واضعافها نددت موسكو
بالاطراف الداعمه في الحرب الدائره اذ قال
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
ان الارهاب وصف ينطبق على نظام كييف ومن
يقف وراءه وخاصه الامريكيين والا ربيين
الذين اختاروا طريق الحرب ضدنا على حد
تعبيره من بيلجورود الى كييف تاخذ المعارك
منعطفات جديده لا تغير شيئا في حقيقه ان
الحرب ابعد من ان تضع اوزارها قريبا
بالرغم من تكلفتها الباهضه السياسيا
وعسكريا على من في اوروبا وخارجها وعلى
اعضاء وغير اعضائي الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف
النيتو